Hilary Clinton is back and she is worse
than ever Plus Rex Tillerson is out it's
time for exit as well Republicans in the
House are about to try to vindicate
Trump on the Russian collusion stuff we
will talk about all of these things and
much much more i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
Rex mortuus s that means the king is
dead but it also means the Rex Tillerson
is out so he's the Secretary of State
but not anymore he's no longer the
Secretary of State he was fired this
morning via tweet in perfectly Trump in
fashion we will get to all of that so
many things to talk about today so many
great things Trump is also visiting
California and he's visiting the wall
prototypes because this is something
that we do now all right
I mean sure well it's funny I'll talk
about all those things plus I'm just a
buncha but first I want to say thank you
to my sponsors over at Birch gold so
does it seem like things are volatile
like you don't know what's going on like
things may be slightly chaotic of course
it does because they are which is why
you need to at least take some of your
money and put it into precious metals
that's where my friends at Birch gold to
come in right now thanks to a
little-known IRS tax law you can even
move your IRA or eligible 401k into an
IRA backed by physical gold and silver
it's perfect for people who want to
protect their hard-earned savings from
inflation and from the volatility of the
stock market Birch gold group of the
people you should trust they have a
long-standing track record of continued
success thousands of satisfied clients
countless 5-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau contact
Birch gold group right now and request a
free information kit on physical
precious metals it's a comprehensive 16
page kit and it reveals how gold and
silver can protect your savings how you
can legally move that IRA or 401k into a
precious metals IRA ask all your
questions and then once you feel
comfortable talk to my friends over at
Birch gold if you want that kid that no
cost no obligation kit go to
birchgold.com slash Ben that's
birchgold.com slash Ben use that slash
Ben so that they know that we sent you
again they're the folks that I trust
with my precious metals investing all
right so we begin today with the ouster
of Rex Tillerson as I say they the
Oedipus Rex Tyrannosaurus Rex the Rex it
he's gone
okay so Rex Tillerson was always a
crappy Secretary of State who's got a
complete disconnect with the President
of the United States the president did
not care in the slightest what Rex
Tillerson had to say about anything like
anything thanking Forex Tillerson
ordered ordered a steak for dinner then
president Trump would send it back and
get a hamburger I mean this is just the
way it went with him Rex Tillerson they
never got along
Tillerson always wanted to run foreign
policy Trump didn't want any part of
that you recall the President Trump
actually tweeted out in the middle of
Rex Tillerson talking with the North
Koreans that Rex Tillerson should not
talk with the North Koreans
see the
thing about Trump and you know one of
the right fears that Trump was gonna run
a secret agenda when he was president
who won't gonna know what he was
thinking and then there's this thing
called Twitter where it's legitimately
just him vomiting his thoughts and
Twitter says like there's a big secret
about Rex Tillerson he doesn't like the
guy thinks that Rex teller sins of
schmuck which is true Rex Tillerson was
basically marginalized inside his own
State Department no one cared what he
had to say on Tuesday morning the
president tweeted out his fire of Rex
Tillerson because this is the way you
should totally get rid of cabinet level
officers is by tweeting out that they're
gone and then they look around and go
wait what now huh
so he this Alice oh how he got rid of
James Comey as you recall he had him
fired in the middle of an event for the
FBI out on the west coast the president
the United States running government by
it by Twitter listen I'm happy with the
move I didn't like Rex Tillerson I think
he's a terrible Secretary of State I
think he's been utterly utterly useless
all of the good moves the Trump
administration has made have been made
in spite of teller syns opinion
Tillerson has been marginalized in the
process for a very long time so Trump
tweeted the south is 18 right so here is
what he tweeted out is that the was this
Mike Pompeo director of the CIA will
become our new Secretary of State he
will do a fantastic job thank you to Rex
Tillerson for his service Jeana Haspel
will become the new director of the CIA
and the first woman so chosen
congratulations to all I mean not all
right congratulations everybody except
for Rex Tillerson whose new job
apparently Tillerson had no idea that he
was actually going to be fired parently
so the Washington Post reported that Rex
Tillerson was told that he was on the
ropes as of last Friday now the reason
that's important is because yesterday
Rex Tillerson did a whole press campaign
about how terrible Russia was he was
talking specifically about how the
Russian government had killed apparently
in X so via in X Russian spy in Great
Britain and the UK was targeting Russia
over this and Tillerson said yeah the
Russians killed this spy as well as one
other person and they are and they're in
our crosshairs and then the White House
backed off and out they said no no no
you know we'll look at it maybe we'll
kind of look at it right here here was
Trump today for example talking about
Russia getting the facts straight this
clip 17 as soon as we get the facts
straight and we're going to be speaking
with the British today we're
speaking with Theresa May today and as
soon as we get the facts straight if we
agree with them we will condemn Russia
or whoever it may be but I have not
spoken to our speaker sometime today
okay so the so again there that seems
pretty soft on Russia but what people
were assuming is that because Tillerson
was harsh on russia yesterday and trump
didn't want to be harsh on russia he
fired Tillerson that's total nonsense
that's not why he X tell us until
Orson's been on the chopping block for a
long time john bolton was in the oval
office like last week
people have been expecting Tillerson to
be gone for literally months and then
Trump would tweet out every so often no
I loved Rex he's staying which is always
code for we're gonna get rid of him as
soon as we possibly can so here was
Trump actually explaining why I got rid
of Rex Tillerson and this ring sort of
true this is clip 19 Rex and I have been
talking about this for a long time we've
got along actually quite well but we
disagreed on things when you look at the
Iran deal I think it's terrible I guess
he fit it was okay
I wanted to either break it or do
something and he felt a little bit
differently so we were not really
thinking the same Rex is a very good man
I like Rex a lot I really appreciate his
commitment and his service and I'll be
speaking directly over a long period of
time okay so what that really means is I
will never talk to Rex again I hate that
guy's guts
he's the worst also I sent him away
because I don't agree with him about
anything that's that's the actual when
he says I'll be speaking to Rex for a
very long period of time you can speak
for him for a full year after your
points never Secretary of State so I'm
gonna go no on that Rex Tillerson now
Mike Pompeo is in that's actually a very
good move for the administration Mike
Pompeo is much more pro-israel he is
much more anti Iran he's one of the
leading voices during the Obama
administration criticizing Obama for not
using the phrase radical Islamic
terrorism he and Trump seem to be very
much on the same page on foreign policy
which is good the presidents of the
United States and the Secretary of State
should be on the same page with regard
to foreign policy now Trump says that
he's getting close to the cabinet he
wants which is kind of hilarious since
the president picks his own cabinet all
right this is sort of like saying that
you ordered at a restaurant and you're
getting very close to the order that you
want well no that's that like what he
like you made the cabinet do but here's
Trump saying that he's getting close
that's what Jeff Sessions said close but
no cigar
it's
and they're a bunch of people who are
still on Trump's hit list inside the
cabinet here was Trump talking about how
he is now perfecting his cabinet which
is true okay Pompeo is better than
Tillerson you know a lot of people very
well over the last year and I'm really
at a point where we're getting very
close to having the cabinet and other
things that I want I don't know what the
other things are is like a horse or what
but it but I like that he is making his
cabinet better okay tell hjerson being
gone
yeah is a good thing again the president
was also running over teller since head
with regard to North Korean policy who's
running over his head with regard to
Russian policy it doesn't make sense to
have a Secretary of State who is not
doing what you want him to do the
president is the Secretary of State's
boss he can get rid of him although
again it's kind of a gutless move to get
rid of him on Twitter as opposed to
calling him up and saying listen Rex
thanks for your service you're out right
probably hear the dirty little secret
about Trump is that he actually doesn't
like firing people he likes to make his
underlings fire people he got famous for
going on TV and saying if I it but he
doesn't actually like doing that that
was just for the cameras in reality
Trump is very hesitant about firing
people he tends to make them resign or
he tries to pressure them to resign like
Jeff Sessions or he will fire them
through Twitter or all of a sudden the
reason that matters is because a feeling
of chaos within the Trump administration
does not quiet the worries of the
American people if you just looked at
the policy coming out of the Trump
administration as I've been saying for a
long time I like a lot of the policy but
the American people feel uneasy with
President Trump they feel uneasy because
they feel like he is a he is a whirlwind
of chaos mainly because he is a world
willing to cast him in the same day they
gets heard and Rex Tillerson John
McEntee who's the longtime personal
assistant to Trump was abruptly escorted
out of the White House in another
dramatic staff change so he was the trip
director for Trump's campaign he'd be
like the guy who brought Trump a Sharpie
when it was time to sign something he
was a body man apparently he was fired
according to CNN because he's under
investigation by the Department of
Homeland Security for serious financial
crimes a source told the network my
source familiar with his firing told the
network the circumstances were not
related to Trump he was actually removed
so quickly that he left without his
jacket and somebody had to go back in
for his jackets who's ejected from the
White House and then and then the most
hilarious thing is that he was
immediately hired by the Trump campaign
so as soon as the story comes out that
he might be dirty and there's a problem
with him then all of a sudden he is
immediately hired by the Trump campaign
other people joining the Trump campaign
I love this Katrina Pierson yeah she's
back
and she's joining the Trump campaign
once again the greatest spokesperson of
all time which means then we'll have
many more hours of analyzing funny video
to come in future episodes of the ben
shapiro show so we're very excited about
the rehiring
of Katrina Pierson very very solid stuff
but there's been a lot of turnover
apparently inside the the Trump staff
John Kelly obviously removing the the
security clearances for a lot of folks
inside Trump staff the reason all this
is a problem again is when there's a
perception of chaos that actually has
consequences politically so the
president always loses seats in an
off-year elections it's very rare that
doesn't happen the last time that it
happened was 2002
so presidents always lose seats in
off-year elections the question is how
many seats the Republicans are actually
going to lose in 2018 they right now
have a 23 seat majority in the house if
it was any more than that they lose the
majority there apparently 37 open
Republican seats Republicans who have
either retired resigns or moved on to
other positions that are not think 12 to
14 Democratic seats in there that are
available in the same way one of the
bellwethers is supposed to happen
tonight so one of the hot pieces of news
is that tonight there's an election in
Pennsylvania's 18th congressional
district now this thing is an interim
election it's only gonna last for like
the next couple of months but the
contest is happening in a district that
Trump won by 20 points and it pits GOP
candidate Rick second a member of the
Pennsylvania House of Representatives
against a much younger Democrat named
Connor Lam who's a former federal
prosecutor and a Marine again Trump won
this district going away and no Democrat
has run a competitive race in this
district in two decades the closest
election of the last eight races was 15
points separating the Republican from
the Democrat but Tim Murphy who is the
Republican resigned from his seat after
news broke that he'd impregnated his
then mistress and allegedly told her to
get an abortion so he resigned and that
left the seat open well right now the
Democrat is slightly favored to win the
seat and you can tell there's a lot of
heartache and heartburn inside the
Republican in the halls of power the
presidents in the United States through
sec hone under the bus the other day he
said he's a bad candidate and he's not a
great candidate but he's not like a Roy
Moore type disaster candidate wrecks at
Cohn but it doesn't matter ii will
probably lose or at the very least it
will be a very competitive race in a
district that shouldn't have a
competitive race and here's the problem
this is being used as an indicator for
future results in 2018 democrats have
really well in special elections across
the country so Trump is said listen
we're winning districts all over the
country all these special elections have
still gone to Republicans right but
that's not the question the question is
how much the vote has shifted since 2016
between 2016 and 2017 or 2016 and 2018
and the answer is quite a lot so in just
a second I'm gonna give you the
statistical breakdown on exactly how all
of this goes down but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over and
my Patriot supply so building an
emergency food storage plan is the
cornerstone of preparedness and
everybody in the office is doing that
with the experts in my Patriot supply
right now is the time for you to build
that foundation make sure that you are
safe in case of natural disaster in case
of man-made disaster you don't want to
be stuck in your house of no access to
food and that's why you can get the Ben
Shapiro special offer from my Patriot
supply today by one four week emergency
food kit for just 198 bucks and you get
one free as well so it's a buy one get
one free deal these kids normally sell
for 217 bucks which means the two of
them would sell for 434 dollars
purchase one right now at the low sale
price of 198 and my patron supply will
send you an additional four week food
kit for free so pretty solid deal you
buy it once you never have to worry
about it again because these things last
25 years in storage includes breakfast
lunches dinners packaged in a rugged
slimline tote call eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen that's
eight eight eight eight oh three 14 13
or order online and prepare with Ben
comm there's a purchase limit of two per
order and supplies are limited to do it
now you know this is the last time we're
gonna be mentioning this really really
solid offer eight eight eight eight oh
three fourteen thirteen that's eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen or prepare with Ben calm again
don't get caught off guard prepare with
Ben calm is the is the place to go when
you're looking to prepare your family in
case of disaster and again there's not a
lot of money to spend to protect your
family it toss it in the closet you
forget about it until disaster strikes
at which point you're the only guy in
the neighborhood who is actually
prepared prepare with Ben calm for that
special offer buy one get one free
4-week emergency food kit 198 bucks
alright so here's how the statistics
break down and how Democrats have been
doing in districts across the country in
these special elections so the answer is
they've been doing quite well okay so in
2017 there were one two three four five
six seven there were seven special
elections in 2017
okay the partisan lean in these
districts when something like that
California 34th was a d-plus 69 district
meaning that it's a huge gap between
Republicans and Democrats
the Kansas fourth was our +29 Montana
out large was our plus 21
Georgia six Lazar plus nine South
Carolina fifth was our plus nineteen
Utah third was our plus 35 and Alabama
US Senate was our plus 29 right how did
it actually swing so Republicans won all
of the seats they were supposed to win
but the swing was enormous so Kansas
fourth as I say it's in our +29 district
normally that race was only won by the
Republican by six points that's a 23
point swing in favor of Democrats
Montana 16 point swing Georgia six six
points wing South Carolina fifth 16
point swing Utah third three points wing
Alabama US Senate of course was won by
the actual Democrat and that was a 31
points wing so that means on average you
are talking about a 16 point swing in
favor of Democrats if that Hel's if that
holds true there's no question
Republicans lose the house if that sort
of turnout holds true Democrats are
energized Republicans are frankly not
and in Pennsylvania the candidate there
has stopped campaigning on the tax cuts
because apparently that's not actually
getting one out anybody out to vote
instead the candidate is campaigning on
cultural issues which makes a lot of
sense and gives the lie to the idea that
Republicans are going to win based on
the state of the economy or based on
policy victories people do not win
elections based on policy victories not
in today's day and age unfortunately
they win based on culture war issues and
culture war issues are where Republicans
do have an advantage because the
Democrats are so off the reservation
when it comes to the culture war the
Democrats are the ones pushing
intersectional politics the Democrats
are the ones suggesting that Republicans
and Republican voters are stupid and
nasty and poor well we'll get to Hillary
Clinton in just a second because really
is incredible what Democrats are saying
about Republicans but again this is why
a lot of the this is why a lot of the
chaos inside the Trump administration
matters the more you the more you worry
about the President of the United States
the more you want to check on the
President of the United States Trump
again already blaming seccond for
pre-emptive loss there's no reason to
think any generic Republicans should
have lost the seat in any case so we'll
keep our eyes obviously on the
Pennsylvania 18th and give you all of
the updates there but that said again
this breaks down a long few lines the
Trump administration is improving there
is better news
coming out of the Trump administration
the the staffing is better over there
they are cleaning house but that that
propensity toward a feeling of of chaos
continues now speaking of the culture
war when vice president Mike Pence is an
emissary of the culture war and I'm
telling you Mike Pence what he has to
say about Joy Behar from the view is
much more important to voters believe it
or not then even the tax cut so Joy
Behar of course went on national
television and said that Mike Pence is a
crazy person for saying God speaks to
him and then she had to apologize
here's what pence had to say about it on
Hannity show last night on Fox News when
when I heard that ABC had a program
where my Christian faith had been
described as a mental illness I thought
it was important for me to speak out not
on my own behalf you and I know the
criticism comes with public life but I
felt it was important that I defend the
faith of tens of millions of Americans
against I think against that kind of
slander okay he is right and it's one of
the reasons why Democrats have been
losing in the culture wars it's also one
of the reasons why president Trump is
out in California visiting the border
wall so in just a second I'm gonna show
you the actual president Trump pictures
at the border wall he he got on the
helicopter and now he's getting on Air
Force One he's flying all the way out to
California so that he can come to a
photo-op with a bunch of concrete and we
have some pictures actually we have some
of some video of the Trump wall
prototypes the President Trump will be
visiting today in California again he is
it one two three four he declares a
culture war again the idea here is that
when you declare a culture war you are
more likely to be successful than if you
campaign on policy because people vote
on the basis of character not on the
basis of policy here is what the border
while prototypes look like the president
Trump will be visiting when he comes out
to Los Angeles now what it does seem
like for people can't see there's a
bunch of different border wall
prototypes it looks sort of like if
you're going to shop for linoleum at
your local furniture your local
furniture Emporium it's like Home Depot
but I will say there's a major problem
with these border wall prototypes
they're giant holes between them
it looks like the illegal immigrants can
just run right through them and frankly
it looks like they can just drive a bus
right between there so I hope that they
fix that before they actually implement
I hope the president comes and makes
clear that the board walls actually
should be pushed together I know who did
this but whoever did that should be
fired me it's just terrible this is okay
I'm joking people I know I know
these are just prototypes okay so the
president is gonna come out here he's
going to show that he likes the border
wall they'll know that he's hoping to
get the Republican base jinda in that
way he will probably do so because
Democrats will respond to this by saying
it's just terrible
how could Trump visit a bunch of
concrete look at this photo op he hates
immigrants racist racist racist and then
Democrats will shoot themselves in the
foot now speaking of shooting themselves
in the foot Hillary Clinton was it was
tripping all over herself yesterday I
mean not just verbally like actually
physically they would clip 14 yesterday
she was actually coming down the stairs
she was in India and she slipped not
once but twice coming down the stairs
she obviously I mean she is less stable
on her feet than my grandmother my
grandmother has 20 years on her here's
Hillary Clinton dressed in a muumuu
coming down the stairs in India what is
she wearing fits like a hospital patient
here she comes down the stairs and up
and down goes hillary down goes hillary
Howard Cosell impersonation alright
here's you up and down those Hillary
again it's like the Joe Frazier Foreman
pop and there those are shoe there she
opposed shoes are gone now she's walking
barefoot now she's going and she's got
two people supporting her my favorite
part of that video if you run him back
is that I believe it's Huma Abedin
behind her and who may happen and does
not even react right who was like oh
yeah Hillary does this all the time
remember when we were told that Hillary
was perfectly healthy and all as well no
not for people who are saying that the
stairs were slippery first of all
slippery stairs is a great Japanese show
but has nothing to do with this but I
just felt like making the reference but
second of all I think that it is worth
noting that no one else was walking down
these stairs is slipping except for who
slips twice and then kicks off her shoes
yeah but everybody who asked about her
health was totally crazy in the last
election cycle that wasn't the worst
slipping down the stairs for Hillary or
slipping down the stairs for Hillary
came yesterday during an interview on
India Today in which she slandered poor
people and people in red states as well
as other women now for those who can't
see Hillary is actually apparently
wearing Steve Urkel's pants in this
interview so she's she's sitting there
talking about why she lost and and going
did I lose that so here's Hillary
Clinton talking about about why people
voted for Trump instead
for Her Majesty if you look at the map
of the United States there's all that
red in the middle where Trump won
now I win the coasts I win you know
Illinois and Minnesota places like that
but what the map doesn't show you is
that I won the places that represent
two-thirds of America's gross domestic
product it wasn't there for a second
before we go further so first of
all that is the stupidest argument ever
right she's now arguing that basically
there should be a per capita GDP rating
on whether your votes count so if not if
not on earning because the fact is that
if you're a higher earner you voted
Republican on average from voters were
slightly wealthier than Hillary voters
but she's saying if you're from a higher
earning area then we should vote for you
so this is a difference between Trump
voters and Hillary voters there are a
lot of rich Trump voters but they live
out in the hinterlands they live in
Texas they live in Montana they live out
in a bunch of places that are not
particularly high earning as a
generality a lot of Hillary voters are
people who are not necessarily rich but
they do live in high earning areas like
Manhattan or Los Angeles or Seattle big
cities because Hillary's motored voting
base tends to be more urban urban there
is not a euphemism for black by the way
her voting base tends to be a
significantly more City based than then
Trump's voting base but that's an that's
a crazy concept but she just said that
right when she says that people are my
votes are more valuable because they
come from areas that earn more funny
when Mitt Romney said sort of the same
thing in 2012 people shellac them for it
but the left is sort of letting Hillary
go on this one to a certain extent okay
so before I go further actually gets
worse for Hillary before I go any
further first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at legacy box so as I
have said many many times I think the
most important thing one of the most
important things you can do in life is
preserve your memories because your
brain ain't always going to be able to
call up all of those memories you're not
always going to be able to remember all
of those wonderful times you had with
your kids or with your parents that's
why you really do have to preserve your
pictures you have to preserve it your
videos we've done this over at the
Shapiro house with legacy box the way it
works you go in your garage you get all
those old tapes all those old reels all
those old pictures and you send them in
a box to the folks over at legacy box
you can put barcodes on all your
materials so that you can track it
throughout the process you put it in the
box you send it back to my friends at
legacy box and they send you back all of
the material plus a digitally preserved
DVD or thumb drive so you get all of
that material back
DVD or thumb drive so if God forbid
there's a flood at your house or you
just want to take it on vacation you
just pop it on your keychain and you're
ready to go you've got all your memories
right there
on your keychain because you use legacy
box again all your old tapes films
pictures audio recordings everything
they will put all of that on a DVD or
thumb drive for you they take care of
everything they provide updates at every
step in the process and we've used it in
the Shapiro house I've used it for my
parents it's a really great present by
the way it makes a really good Mother's
Day or Father's Day gifts over 350,000
families have used them for a limited
time go to legacy box comm slash Ben and
you get a 40 percent discount on your
order that's a legacy box comm slash Ben
and you get a 40 percent discount on a
on a product that's already wildly
affordable so legacy box comm slash Ben
you get that 40 percent discount on your
order use the slash banner for the
discount plus let them know we sent you
I think it's a really important product
actually so you should really get get to
know the folks over at legacy box comm
there at legacy box legacy box comm /
Ben for the discount okay so that was
not the worst thing that Hilary said so
Hilary starts off by saying listen the
places I won are the more important
places right I won the places where all
the money is and then people wondered
why people thought that she was a tool
of like Goldman Sachs and Wall Street
maybe it's because she's openly saying
she's a tool of Goldman Sachs and Wall
Street then it gets even worse
she starts labeling the people she says
the people who live in high-income areas
these are better people than the people
who voted for Trump people voted for me
are better human beings than people who
voted for Trump sort of an amazing
contention but here she goes so I won
the places that our optimistic diverse
dynamic moving forward and his whole
campaign make America great again was
looking backwards you know you didn't
like black people getting rights you
don't like women you know getting jobs
you don't want it you know see that
Indian Americans succeeding more than
you are whatever your problem is I'm
gonna solve it so Hillary Hillary's
voters were just superior humans now
this is one of the reasons she lost the
election when you call half the voting
American public deplorable turns out
they think that you're kind of a jerk
hey Hillary was the worst hand in
American history and she proves it every
single day I just hope that Hillary
continues to be on the public stage and
Democrats are forced to defend her I'd
love to see Tom Perez the head of DNA
see be forced to answer questions about
Hillary's perspective on the American
voter but that's an amazing contrast
she's drawn and here's why Democrats if
they take this to heart are going to
lose because their view is that the
people who voted for Hillary Clinton are
superior better humans than the people
who voted for Donald Trump they actually
believe that the folks who pulled the
trigger for Hillary are more optimistic
and diverse and dynamic and moving
forward even though there's no evidence
that they're more optimistic right maybe
more racially diverse
I mean her coalition was more racially
diverse than Trump's but so what
in dynamic moving for what does that
even mean that they wanted more
socialistic government she won the
places that are more optimistic but the
people from the other side those
terrible terrible people they're just
garbage when Democrats say this when
they believe this what it means they're
gonna double down on the good people
right they're gonna double down on the
optimistic diverse dynamic moving
forward people which means the
intersectional coalition they're gonna
keep ignoring the people who voted in
Ohio and Michigan and Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin they're gonna keep just saying
that those people are bad people which
is why they voted for Trump and maybe if
you insult them enough they'll vote for
you Hillary maybe if you insult them
enough Democrats they'll vote for you
maybe if you tell them that they're
beneficiaries of white privilege who are
looking backwards then suddenly they
will resonate to your cause but somehow
I doubt it that last line that that
trumps whole pitch and it worked with
these people was you don't like black
people getting rights name anything
Trump said during the campaign or ever
as far as I'm aware in which he said he
wanted black people's rights removed and
don't give me voter ID that's not a
right okay everyone uses voter ID in
states all over the country we use ID to
buy alcohol we use ID for lots of stuff
that's not a racist policy this is you
don't like women getting jobs when did
Trump ever say he didn't like women
getting jobs he said I don't want this
woman getting this job he doesn't want
Hillary Clinton becoming president but
women getting jobs mean Trump's
relatively famous for his daughter being
a pretty successful businesswoman right
Ivanka is a very successful
businesswoman he doesn't seem to have a
lot of trouble with that I have a lot of
problems with Trump these are not the
problems black people getting rights is
a problem for Trump you don't like women
getting jobs you don't want to see that
Indian Americans succeeding more than
you are who does she think is this is
the United Nations ambassador the United
Nation from the United States is nikki
Haley an Indian American in the two
states that have had Indian American
governments a governor's our North
Carolina
Haley and Louisiana with bobby jindal
both of them voted for Trump in the last
election cycle I mean it was it was Joe
Biden not Donald Trump who's making
jokes about a poo style Indian people at
7-eleven and then this is all is all
nonsense and and it's very helpful for
Democrats because again they want to
portray themselves as the better people
than the rest of us over at 5:38
actually whose box com they had a whole
article about how Trump voters are more
racist than Hillary voters ignoring of
course the fact that a lot of Hillary
voters are racist in reversed fashion
that when you when you spend an entire
campaign talking about white privilege
and how America is terrible and how
white people have victimized black
people all across America and continue
to do so when you do that that tends to
veer into racism very very quickly and
it tends to veer into a sneering snide
nasty looking down your nose at all of
these Americans this sort of
paternalistic view of these these stupid
people who live in the middle of the
country this is why Hillary Clinton lost
and then she continued along these lines
so she again she's looking for everyone
to blame she's now blamed pretty much
everyone on earth except herself for her
her election loss she said that she
blames women because married women voted
for Trump but why did married women vote
for Trump well they voted for Trump of
course because they're little Tammy
Wynette types right who stand by their
man the reason the married women voted
for Trump is because married women voted
like their husbands and their husbands
basically they the old Bob comes down
from his from his job at beer factory
and it comes in and gets his whooping
stick he says to his wife honey
you better get out there and vote drunk
on the whooping stick that is Hillary's
actual vision of how married women in
the United States vote here is Hillary
Clinton explaining what happened in my
election is I was on the way to winning
white women until informer director the
FBI Jim Comey dropped that very
ill-advised letter on October the 28th
and my numbers just went down because
all and I heard a lot of anecdotal
evidence about this people have written
about it all of a sudden you know white
women who were going to vote for me and
frankly standing up to the men in their
lives and the men in their workplaces
we're being told she's going to jail you
know you don't want to vote for her you
know it's a bit terrible you can't vote
for that so it just it's stopped
my momentum and it decreased my vote
enough because I was I was I had I was
winning and I thought I had fought my
way back in the ten days from that
letter until the election I fell a
little bit short and so I think that it
it was part of a historical trend that I
was bucking and then it collapsed on me
okay that is not true in the slightest
Hillary Clinton with regard to married
women won almost precisely the same
percentage of the vote as Barack Obama
or John McCain married women always vote
Republican Donald Trump won 53% of white
mera I believe is 53% of white married
women in the United States Mitt Romney
won 52% and John McCain won 51% so they
weren't exactly the same percentage
meaning it has very little to do with
Hillary Clinton Hillary is providing a
rather flattering account of her own
election but there's some more here that
I want to discuss something about
married versus unmarried that I think is
going under the radar a piece of data I
think you should know first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
this is war so there's a this is war is
brand-new Apple podcast okay it is
fantastic okay this is war is a
wandering podcast and it is a it is
essentially veterans telling their
stories it's sharing the personal
stories of the brave men and women
who've served in our armed forces these
are first-hand accounts of what it's
like to fight and survive combat in
foreign lands Iraq and Afghanistan
protecting our freedom the bonds that
are formed the physical the physical and
psychological toll it often takes on a
human being what it's like to return
home in the first episode I've I've
listened to the preview it's really
phenomenal and and really moving and I
think that important listening for
everybody who of course stands with our
troops in the first episode you meet Ian
meirin's a month a month before his
senior year in high school when he was
17 years old he walked into a
recruitment office and signed up that
was August of 2001 of course the world
changed on September 11th and he was
entering military under very different
circumstances yet his whole story over
at this is war a wonder a podcast so
check it out at Apple podcast or
wherever you're listening to this
podcast just head on over to this is war
and subscribe or visit wondering if M
slash been as Wondra dot F M slash been
wonder with why dot F M slash been
subscribed listen it's really moving and
it's really great and you should
definitely check it out so again that
podcast is called this is war and I
think that you'll find it riveting
listening it really is fantastic stuff
this is war from laundry check it out
okay so
we are going to continue discussing
Hillary's false blame of the American
people for her own awful candidacy but
first you're gonna have to go over to
Daily wire and subscribe so over it
daily wire for $9.99 a month you can get
the rest of this show live get the rest
of Clavin show live there are some
Knowles show Live Plus today the episode
of the conversation is coming today
5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific I
will sit next to Ely Shack rouse and
you'll read questions at me okay you
will be able to do that and ask me the
questions when you are a subscriber so
go do that right now subscribe today be
part of the conversation so I can answer
your questions in an hour long live Q&A
my conversation will stream live on the
bench appear on Facebook page daily why
our YouTube channel it's free for
everybody to watch but only subscribers
are the chosen only subscribers can ask
questions so to ask questions all you
have to do is log in to our website at
daily wire.com head over to the
conversation page and you can watch the
live stream after that start typing into
the daily wired chat box and we will
screen the questions and we will answer
the questions live as they come in for
an entire hour that is happening today
5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific be
there I'm gonna be there so if you're
not there I'm gonna take it personally
so you better be there if I'm wasting my
afternoon on this stuff come on I know
you want to check it out and become a
subscriber that also helps us bring you
the show obviously it helps us employ
the otherwise unemployable derelicts who
populate this office so become a
subscriber for $9.99 a month and when
you get the annual subscription at $99 a
year which is cheaper than 9 9 9 a month
if you do the math look at that brain
power right there then you also get this
the leftist here is hot or cold tumblr
the very greatest in all beverage
vessels if you want to listen later for
free go over to iTunes SoundCloud
YouTube please subscribe please leave
this review we always appreciate it we
are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so you heard Hillary blaming
all of these married women who
apparently listen to old Bob with the
Hickory stick when he comes home from
work and says get you out and go vote
for Trump right that's how Hillary
pictures all these people in the
backwoods of Kentucky right that's
that's that's America breaks down into
two groups of people it breaks down into
the Clintons in the Obamas and then it
breaks down into old Bob with the
Hickory stick out in the middle of
Louisiana right that's that's Hillary's
view of America it's it's very much the
New York Review of America there's a
very famous cover of The New Yorker that
shows what America looks like from the
perspective of a New Yorker and Hillary
is basically a New Yorker and you know
whether she grew up in Chicago is
irrelevant and she's got the attitude of
a lot of folks from New York and that
attitude is that America looks something
like this they chose a map of the United
States from the New Yorkers perspective
and so what the map shows is here's New
York with a lot of big buildings and
then it shows like nothing for about
three inches and then there's LA and up
here is Chicago and down here is Dallas
and that's it right the rest of the
country just doesn't exist the entirety
of the country is New York and then the
other coast right there's nothing
between the coasts and that's how
Hillary views America if you are
anywhere in the middle of the country if
you're in flyover country then this
means that you are a bad person you are
an irresponsible person or you're a
woman who's being bullied by her husband
now I do find it ironic that Hillary
Clinton a woman who stood by her husband
while he was be incredibly accused of
rape as well as multiple other sexual
assault and misconduct that she's
claiming that women are subject to the
whims of their husbands okay no one was
more subject to whims of their husband
that Hillary Clinton who wrote her
husband's coattail to near glory before
collapsing right on the precipice and
falling down the stairs but it's
important to mention something there's a
lot of talk about why do married women
shift into Republicans when they get
married well some people say that it's
because they're listening to their
husbands now and this means that they
are going to you know listen to the
whims of their husbands and men tend to
vote Republican more often than women
but this isn't neglecting another fact
okay here's the other fact unmarried men
vote Democrat more often than married
men if you look at the marital status by
gender okay these are the exit polls
from the last election cycle among
married men Trump one married men
fifty-seven percent to 38 percent among
unmarried men unmarried men voted for
Hillary Clinton
46% to 44% so in other words unmarried
men voted much more like unmarried women
than unmarried men voted like married
men and that's kind of an amazing
statistic that unmarried men voted
Democrat and married men voted
Republican and there was a pretty
significant gap there you're looking at
at least a 10-point gap looks like an
11-point gap between unmarried men and
married men among unmarried women versus
married women married women vote 49
percent to 47 percent for hillary
clinton white married women voted
overwhelmingly for trump unmarried women
voted 63 percent for hillary clinton and
32 percent for trump so there was a
14-point shift for married women and
about an 11-point shift for married men
okay which suggests that it's something
that has to do with marriage not just
male and female there's something that
has to do with marriage that makes
people vote more Republican that is not
a shock that is not a shock part of it
is that because merit marriage is a
self-selecting group so the people who
choose to get married tend to be more
traditional than the people who choose
not to get married if you choose not to
get married much better shot that you
are on the left just generally
particularly if you stay single for a
long period of time but there is
something to the idea that marry
marriage actually does change human
beings marriage makes people more
committed to the future marriage makes
people think about somebody beyond
themselves marriage makes you feel
dependent not on the government anymore
but on the person to whom you are
married your first line of defense is no
longer the guy who works at the local
office but instead it is the guy who
lives in your house or the woman who
lives in your house the marriage does
change human beings and I think marriage
makes people a lot better I think this
is why marriage is an institution has
been the bedrock of Western civilization
marriage is vital if the gap is not that
men women are getting married and then
they listen to their evil terrible
redneck husbands it's that married it's
the men are voting Democrat and women
are voting Democrat and then they decide
you know what I'm gonna make something
of myself I'm gonna make something in my
life I'm gonna build a future here and
that requires me to for example keep
more of my own money it also is going to
require me to carve out a certain
private space in which government cannot
intervene it's going to require me to
have a certain area where I am capable
of raising my family in peace and quiet
it's going to require me to have
religious freedom so I can raise my
family in principles that I think are
important marriage makes people better
plus women make men better and men make
women better hey the I don't think that
all human beings make
but I do think that as a general level
on a general level what it says in the
Bible about a woman completing a man a
man completing a woman I think this is
right I think one of the most important
messages in the beginning of Genesis is
a man shut the Sam and she'll leave his
father and his mother and shall cleave
to his wife
right that's the whole point of marriage
that you become an independent human
being when you get married you break off
from your parents you break off from
your paternal figure which in some cases
is the government you break off from
people who make you dependent and
instead you stand up on your own feet
alongside somebody that you love and now
you forge your life together and that
has political ramifications this is not
to say the marriage is automatically
gonna shift everybody into a Republican
but it is to say that Hillary Clinton's
simplistic accounts of why women vote
differently when they're single than
when they're married naturally
evil men toxic masculinity is just not
true men themselves shift on politics
once they get married also I think the
general notion by the way that Hillary's
voters are nicer people are better
people than people voted for Trump is
just absolute sheer crap I travel all
around the country I've spent most of my
life living in blue areas virtually all
of my life actually living in blue areas
strike that all of my life living in
blue hair I've lived all of my 34 years
either in Los Angeles for Cambridge
Massachusetts some of the most liberal
areas in the country and that there's no
correlation between the politics of the
areas and the niceness of the people in
fact the nicest people that I've met are
generally not in those big cities
there's a reason people don't like
people from New York or people from Los
Angeles as much as they like people from
Oklahoma and Midwestern people tend to
be a little bit much nicer a lot more
cordial I remember the first time I was
in Oklahoma I was I was walking around
Oklahoma's I must been maybe 20 21 I was
guest hosting a radio show and I was
walking on the street and I caught eyes
with some lady and if you do this in a
big city if you if you're from a big
city you know exactly what I'm talking
about if you're from LA Chicago New York
if you ever catch rise with somebody on
the street mathis what's the natural
response to catching eyes on somebody on
the street in Los Angeles you look away
right that's that's why you do you look
away because it's super awkward and it's
really it you don't want to talk to that
person you don't know whether that
person is gonna pull a knife on you and
stab you in the face you don't know
whether the person is gonna scream at
you you don't know what it's gonna be
right but in the Midwest it's a little
different so if I remember I was in
Oklahoma and I was walking down the
street as ladies walking the other way
we catch rise to go well hi there and I
pull
my cell phone I called my father I said
where am I what's going on why are
people doing this hey if you there is a
certain level of niceness that exists in
the middle of the country that Hillary
Clinton apparently does not appreciate
or care about all the people in the
middle of the country are terrible
people who are backwards looking and
racist even though again these
statistics by poll data showing that
people in the South are supposedly more
racist than people from the north though
those data are really weak
they really don't exist according to
Gallup racism exists just as much in big
cities like Boston as it does in cities
like Atlanta probably more in Boston
than Atlanta I've been to both places
there's a lot more racism in Boston than
there isn't Atlanta actually there's a
lot more integration in parts of the
south and in parts of the north some of
the most highly segregated cities in the
United States are cities that exist
outside the traditional Southern
Corridor that's north and north of the
mason-dixon line
so again Hillary's generalized takecare
is just wrong and as long as Democrats
continue to follow that take they're
going to continue losing the the
strength of the American people and the
and the willingness of the American
people to follow them okay meanwhile the
President of the United States is
declaring himself vindicated on
collusion so yesterday top Republicans
at the House Intelligence Committee came
out and they said we're about to issue a
report our report says no evidence of
collusion yeah okay so this is where
we're all supposed to pretend that
Republicans were ever going to sort of
condemn Trump right well we're all gonna
pretend for a second that President
Trump was right he was on the ropes that
Devin Nunes was going to come forth and
say you know what Trump turns out the
evidence just was it was against him you
know we're just gonna partisan partisan
investigations tend not to come up with
particularly reliable results I'm not
gonna blame Democrats for saying why
would I believe Devin Nunes okay and I'm
not gonna if it were a Democrat in
office and we're a Democrat
investigating Obama and we're a Democrat
saying Obama has been cleared I would
say that's a bunch of crap I would say
that because it is a bunch of crap okay
in any case Trump tweeted out there is
no collusion right and he all caps he
grabbed his caps lock and he really went
to town he said the House Intelligence
Committee has after a 14 month long
in-depth investigation found no evidence
of collusion or coordination between the
Trump campaign and Russia to influence
the 2016 presidential election I'm only
Ilyn cuz he is it's all caps so that's
that's that's true for what it's worth
by the way I've been saying for pretty
much a year I don't think that there's
any clue
I don't think the Trump campaign could
collude with itself let alone with
Russia I think president Trump was not
even in touch with his own campaign
advisers that place was a chaotic crap
show I mean I know all the people who
are involved in the campaign that was
not a well-run organization okay all of
that said he's not wrong about this but
the the tendency to to credit the House
Intelligence Committee with letting him
off I think is a little bit premature
you can see the panic on the Democratic
side though so Maxine Waters
who is indeed a low IQ human being she
said that she's depending on robert
muller to prove collusion while she may
be waiting for a while cuz I don't think
Muller has the evidence of it either oh
I know is this if he thinks he can stop
me from talking about impeach 45 he's
got another thought coming I am not
intimidated by him I'm gonna keep saying
that we need to impeach him and I am so
depending on our special counsel Robert
Miller to connect the dots so that he
can prove the collusion and of course
we've seen obstruction of justice just
playing out before our very eyes
okay so again I think that if Democrats
are relying on robert muller to save
them from their own incompetence good
luck with that Adam Schiff of course
representative Democrat CNN he he's I'm
from California anyway anymore he's
actually established residency at CNN's
remote location he just sits there all
day and he takes actual constituent
calls from the greenroom at CNN anyway
he tweeted out that this was a tragic
milestone he said breaking GOP just shut
down house Intel investigation leaving
questions unanswered leads unexplored
countless witnesses owned called
subpoenas unissued if russians have
leverage over the president GOP has
decided it would rather not know the
minorities work continues so they're
gonna issue another report suggesting
there was collusion in the absence of
actual evidence it's just a bunch of
allegations again I agree with the
president that this has been wildly
overblown I have yet to see the evidence
that suggests otherwise
I really am not seeing it so yeah I
think that if Democrats are relying on
the the deus ex machina if they're
expecting that there's going to be some
sort of intervention from above by
robert Miller's office I don't really
see that happening but the Republicans
are not doing themselves any favour by
looking hackish so the house Intel
committee also concluded that the
Russians were not interested in seeing
Trump win that's a fine credible
conclusion that's that's quite possible
again it's possible that the Democrat
that the Russians just wanted to
intervene in the election make trouble
because they do this a lot but it's not
a good look when the house Intel
Republicans are saying the CIA just got
it wrong so here is here's one of the
house and tell Republicans saying just
that and when we release that report
we're gonna be able to show you know
what the CIA just got it wrong just like
they did by the way in the Gulf War
where they said there was weapons of
mass destruction that we didn't find the
CIA is not perfect they often or at
least from time to time will make
mistakes as as do i as do you as do any
agency and we're just going to have to
show people they were wrong on this okay
good luck with this this doesn't look a
Koosh at all what he really should have
said is you should have said there is a
wide disparity of opinion among
intelligence agencies about what the
russians actually wanted trump to win
that as far as the evidence shows is
actually true instead he's going
directly after the CIA not a good look
I just I think that if you're going to
tout this House Intelligence report as
kind of be-all-end-all I think that
you're gonna end up in on the wrong side
of on the wrong side of everything I
think that we should wait for Muller to
come down with his evidence we'll
evaluate evidence when it comes down
otherwise it's just hearsay otherwise
it's he said she said nonsense even some
GOP representatives are essentially
saying this one of the GOP
representatives is a guy named Tom
Rooney he's a Florida Republican and
here's what he had to say about the
House GOP Intel committee's announcement
they found no evidence of collusion why
are you all ending it well two things
for what I said last week that we've
gone completely off the rails and now
we're just basically a political forum
for people to leak information to drive
the day's news so we've as use as you
alluded to we've lost all credibility
and we're going to issue probably two
different reports unfortunately so I'm
in that regard I that's why I called for
the investigation and okay so again I
think that you know this is this is
actually right that the the house Intel
Republicans the Intel committee
generally has been corrupted there's no
purpose to the process it's just Adam
Schiff and Devan hoon is slapping each
other it's kind of pointless so we will
wait for the other information to come
out from the Muller investigation if
Democrats are expecting that that's
going to save them again I think that
that's a a sadly mistaken
state of affairs i I do not think that
this is going to save them in any
serious way I think they're in serious
trouble if they continue to follow the
path of hill
clinton and i think that if they're
hoping that that muller is gonna somehow
eject trump from office that's not
happening okay time for some things i
like and then some things i hate and
will deconstruct the culture for a
minute okay so things that i like so
we've been doing books on socialism one
of most famous books on socialism is of
course the road to serfdom by a
Frederick Hayek this is of course the
Lee classic on why state-run economies
are a giant fail we're talking about
this in the aftermath of course of
Elizabeth Broderick the columnist for
The Washington Post calling for a
revision of socialism she says state-run
industries are just great because
they're done for the benefit of the
workers listen there can be a state-run
industry that is productive or that is
run well but not for in an not for an
inordinate period of time because
competition is what weeds everything out
the government itself has no incentive
to be profitable and eventually you will
end up cannibalizing your profits in
order to please political constituencies
it's it's a really fascinating one one
of the fascinating things about the road
to serfdom is that john maynard keynes
who of course was was not a fan of
free-market capitalism in the extreme he
said that this was a grand book and he
said morally and philosophically i find
myself in agreement reversed truly the
whole of it and not only an agreement
with it but in deeply moved to agreement
a really fascinating take it is well
worth the read it's actually not a
particularly hard read the road to
serfdom by Frederick Hayek totally worth
the read published in 1944 when there
were a bunch of folks on the Left who
are openly embracing the socialist
program it's it has a historic role in
the in the revitalization of the
capitalist movement which led to the
rise of the modern conservative movement
as well okay time for you know we'll do
one more thing that I like I mistakenly
labeled this a thing I hate but I do not
hate this in fact I love it Tommy Wiseau
the the guy from the room has now done
an audition tape for the Joker and I
will say that it is not bad like
shockingly it is not bad here is Tommy
Wiseau the weirdest human being ever
playing the weirdest character ever the
Joker what doesn't kill you make you
stranger it's simple we killed the
Batman have you ever danced with a devil
in the pale
like did you know but I did and I did
like it that I'm not the monster okay so
here's the thing I think this kind of
works yeah the reason is because Tommy
Wiseau is actually an insane person
playing an insane person so it's
actually typecasting to certain extent
it all works you put the makeup on him
you get rid of the accents a little bit
and it's not terrible
so he's better than Jared Leto I don't
know let's tell you about that okay time
for a quick thing that I hate so Betsy
DeVos is of course the the Secretary of
Education shoes on 60 minutes and and
Betsy DeVos made herself look not
particularly good she was discussing
education the state of education in
Michigan where she was heavily involved
in the education system and it was not a
good look for the Secretary of Education
here
I hesitate to talk about all schools in
general because schools are made up of
individual students attending them the
public schools here that are doing worse
than they did Michigan schools need to
do better there is no doubt about it
have you seen the really bad schools
maybe try to figure out what what
they're doing I have not I have not
I've not intentionally visited schools
that are underperforming maybe you
should maybe I should yes
okay so she was ripped up and down for
this particular interview again if
members of the press if member of the
administration are not capable of doing
interviews properly it probably
shouldn't be doing the interviews she
didn't know much about the state of
education in the state of Michigan some
of that was a little bit of gotcha
because she's the Secretary of Education
for the whole country not just for the
state of Michigan but again you should
be prepped for this sort of stuff and it
was not a particularly good look okay a
quick episode of deconstructing the
culture so well we haven't done in a
while but it's fun to take pieces of pop
culture and look at them and see how pop
culture shifts Americans opinions on
particular issues well one of our one of
the fans of ben shapiro show sent us a
recommendation so we will do it Keith
Urban is a one of the big country stars
on planet earth right now and he has a
new song called female okay actually
sang it I believe at the at the Country
Music Awards if I'm not mistaken and
this is his performance of the song
female this is how do we put this
propaganda and now the if you want to be
patted on the back by the critics if you
want to be ensure that you are not seen
as a as a bad mean person then you are
supposed to do songs like this
unfortunately it's not a good song
here's here's Keith Urban
[Music]
he
baby
all shout female
so number one I'm not a big fan of songs
that have one note just as a general
rule but beyond that the other lyrics
are when you hear somebody say somebody
hits like a girl how does that hit you
is that such a bad thing when you hear a
song they play saying you run the world
do you believe it will you live to see
it okay I'm so tired of this nonsense
like this is the part that's nonsense
okay first of all women do not rule the
world
okay people rule the world some of those
people are women and some of those
people are men but the idea that you
inherently rule the world just because
you're a woman is really stupid just
like it's a really stupid thing if it's
if it's the opposite the men rule the
world okay this kind of stuff is dumb
okay and when it says when you hear
somebody say somebody hits like a girl
how does that hit you well there is a
difference between how women hit and how
men hit which is why we have separate
wait divisions for men and women it's
why men who are transgender and are
trying to become women should not be
able to compete in UFC with women
because they will legitimately shatter
their faces a men have enormous ly
heavier upper bodies it's just it's
ridiculous then he says there's more of
this kind of stuff when somebody laughs
and implies that she asked for it just
because she was wearing a skirt oh is
that how it works
when somebody talks about how it was
Adam first does that make you
second-best or did he save the best for
last
ah the oh the pandering all the
pandering it's just painful hey I don't
know who is what she's asking for when
she walks down with the short skirt is
that like a thing who's been saying that
because I haven't seen a lot of people
saying that and again this is this
complete mystery to the Bible where it
says that Adam was first and then and
then Eve was created from his rib and
therefore women is inferior that's not
the point of the story the point of the
story is that men and women are the same
and came from the same source and that
man requires women to complete him and
that woman requires man to complete her
okay that's the point of the story it's
not the choose created second and
therefore she was worse if that were the
case you know who was created last
humans right animals were created before
man's that mean that men are secondary
on planet earth according the Bible the
answer of course is no because it's an
idiotic argument it's stupid right God
created bees before he created people
according to the Bible that doesn't mean
that people who came after are suddenly
worse offer or inferior I mean this sort
of pandering is I understand you see it
in novels now you see it in in TV
there's the the pandering moment where
you just need that moment to the movie
in order to get the critics on your side
in
using pop culture with all this stuff
just because critics are left I think is
really is really gross okay we will be
back here at tomorrow and so we will be
we will be back here now we will be back
tomorrow with all the latest news i'm
ben shapiro this adventure Bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Aleksandr Oh
audios mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright floor
publishing 2018